[Music]  true here are some BuzzFeed lists I saw  recently look at this one 8 Kurds who've  never seen Ghostbusters right there  27 kick-ass milk expiration dates 38  punk rock musicians with severe peanut  allergy six kidney stones that fooled a  jeweler check this one out what would  each president look like in a Nissan  Sentra here's this one 16 clowns afraid  of clowns I like this one 11 pieces that  look like wounds yeah whatever  26 ultimate buffet sneeze guard saves  that's a good one quiz which doomed  victim of Pompeii are you 22 Armenians  who are tired of being called Mexican 9  rock formations that kind of look like  boobs if you're squinting and lonely 7  first ladies who stopped giving it  and finally 47 people singing let it go  who were brutally murdered  [Applause]  [Music]  you